this is gonna be tough because I do not
understand American standards of beauty
according to a recent study what
percentage from each gender prefer their
partners to have slender bodies slender
bodies is such a subjective term
what is slender okay so definitely more
men than women I believe I'm gonna say
58% men 68% women whatever we everybody
has their own thing I guess I like to
have you guys anyways so among the list
what physical features on the male body
is considered the least important in
America we all know it's not the jawline
because dear God if you have a good
jawline haul me back it's between
shoulders and jawline for me I'm gonna
say jawline whoa finally one thing right
only ten percent of American women
actually have the body type typically
associated with ideal women body size /
shape in advertisements I would say true
10 percent yeah I would say less than
that because those women are
photoshopped and so how are you supposed
to achieve a Photoshop body some golf
balls we're trained as little girls to
like idolize this one shape that only 5%
of women in America have in a survey by
AARP men and women scored their physical
appearance seven point one on average on
a zero to ten point scale I think we see
ourselves more attractive seven point
one seems about right I don't know it
could be like a six point four I say
false I feel like people are always
under valuing their personal looks I got
a right six point four legitimately I
think seven is a good number to give
yourself this is bull
I just know coming from my own
insecurities I view myself a lot less
than I probably should and I think that
most people do it's just really sad to
see the data behind it these patterns of
how we like judge our attractiveness are
so ingrained and who we are and they're
it's just so hard to let go of them if
you really wanted to find what beauty is
I think beauty it's about who you are as
a person inside don't let people tell
you that you're not important you define
yourself and you let yourself be that to
the world